voilà ils se trouvent sur la glace il
agace kick ass ya des chiens qui tombent
dans l'eau qui en tant que gamin j'étais
très à samaa ça m'a perturbé y at il un
film que vous avez honte d'aimer et qui
vous fait du bien
un film que les accusant d' aimer matin
je sais pas very bad trip chez toi qu
elle électrice qui vous touche le plus
simone signoret si je vous donne carte
blanche pour tourner avec le réalisateur
de vos rêves qui aimeriez vous
collaborez des églises quel autre
principal plaisir professionnels c'est
juste le jeu en général c'est tout
l'univers cessé le travail en général ça
la prépa la réalisation
la presle de partage avec les avec des
partenaires des comédiens tous à quel
autre métier auriez vous pu vous aimez
faire plus haché pas aimé faire plus
c'est pas à citer quelque chose comme ça
quelque chose dans la création non mais
j'ai pas l'esprit mathématique donc pour
moi ça marche pas mais d'architecturé
c'est quelque chose que je que j'aime
beaucoup
est ce que vous apportez un objet
fétiche sur vos tournages nom et où un
film culte stocker 2 à 3 tonnes à dire
la plage en a pleins ceux ci un film qui
vous a traumatisé durant votre enfance
et nous tout le monde un gorille team
oak livre de la savane à quelque chose
comme ça 28' souvient cet énoncé avec
des gens qui se font en ligne chez mais
c'est presque un documentaire je sais
pas quoi je les ai vus quand j'étais
tout petit c'est moi ça m'a fait peur
moi ça n'arrive pas ça